f 6 rules says the suspense is killing
me
well don't die just yet if you like
suspense is the worst thing to die from
at least one of the worst things so yeah
this tournament is being organized by by
Ben Ben and Karen they I think they
attracted a few sponsors who are putting
up a prize fund and I think I can find
the flyer I do have this in my my
schedule and yeah the flyer is linked so
anyway this this is a flyer maybe I can
change the scene here oh it's very small
and there's different sections so for
anyone who wants to buy it you can you
can join you have a minute to join you
just go to chess comm live chess and
then oh my mouse stopped working that
was weird
Kaos is working again yeah you have 45
seconds to join it's under under the
tournament's tab and then you click
whatever section fits your rating so
unfortunate I was not able to choose or
maybe fortunately but anyway there's a
prize fund yeah very generous prize fund
and yeah this has more information so if
you want to find this link maybe I'll
make uh I'll makeup mayhem command and
you may have
maybe I'll update my my stream title to
what people know okay oh I'm playing
business playing someone his name looks
familiar
let's play a London I'm not gonna be
looking too much oh let me change the
scene - yeah that's better
I'm not gonna be looking too much at the
chat because there this is kind of more
serious and there is money on the line
and it's slower chess so have some time
to try and explain my thoughts maybe c4
immediately actually yeah to me Queen b6
with Queen b3 appoint takes I wonder if
this is some kind of opening preparation
it's kind of just like a Slav maybe I
got tricked into some mainline Slav do
you think it's ripped bishops developed
so early I have I have a few moves here
Knight f3 most flexible and then just
Castle the main plan in these positions
is eventually getting e4 so idea rook e1
Knight c3 Queen e2 upon's playing very
quickly try and keep pace h3 is usually
useful can follow some typical London
ideas too but yeah let's play rook e1 so
already threatening e4 expecting 94
I was wondering if I can I could
consider taking in 92
but then the mission moves away it's
still not so easy to play E 4 E 4 cos on
D force hanging I could keep the tension
there's Queen B 3 there's Rick C 1 and
Queen B 3 is kind of interesting also
Bishop d3 Bishop d3 could lead to a lot
of trades does make some sense Queen b3
b5 she may be Queen b3 b5 Bishop f1 but
Queen b3 Queen b6 huh that's interesting
got kind of tricked into position that I
don't know don't exactly know the main
line kind of on my own
rooks see one move you just like rook
see one and rook see one block and take
I have an idea 92 92 I can play it right
away though the whole idea is to gain
the e4 kind of safely and avoid avoid
trades of like I didn't want to trade
off the bishops like I didn't eat for
then this bishop is kind of turned into
a problem piece yeah so I think what
I'll do I do have the chat open hello to
more people but I'm gonna just
completely hide the chat and then I'll
interact with the chat after the game
but yeah let's play study for so feeling
feeling pretty good here and I can come
back to f3 but then Bishop h5 I'm Bishop
e2 let's play that I don't want to like
use up all my time right away let's play
h3 and just solid move if the light
moves here then probably Bishop d3 and
there's some ideas of 95
even Bishop III I'm Queen a5 okay
some Queen b3 just applying some
pressure and there's some small trap if
if Queen b6 I think I can take on e6
because then takes takes all my bishops
hanging but black has so many things
hanging
I guess rook F eights requires more
calculation or rook F 7 takes takes and
clean goes back and I win the night I
would be cool yeah just trying to enjoy
life so that lays b5 so really enticing
me to go for this so the difference here
is c3 is hanging but I don't know if
that makes a huge difference I mean it
still requires calculation and it takes
takes takes if the King moves I I
probably just take on g7 and then take
on d7 all its other line any other line
let me work off seven same thing black
could win c3 in various lines but then
I'll still be up a pawn cuz I'll win
these two pawns I did not mean to play
that again the case of click-click
that's okay I think I I checked most of
the lines that's a danger of drawing
arrows like when I draw arrows I'll
accidentally select a piece and then
when I try and remove the arrow like by
clicking something that case I clicked
up with the black pawn it made the move
yes I realize this only happens when I
stream because when I don't stream I
don't dry rose so and I don't think
there's any way to to disable it it's
happened already a few times this month
but okay upon thinking that's good
so I mean I can pre move this but okay
no need I can maybe look for other moves
for black I mean doc can kind of admit
that he's just losing a pawn and moved
the Knights Oh actually if the knight
moves my bishops almost trapped like
Knight b6 if I played Bishop g4 there's
h5 I think one oh no there's Bishop f5
in that line it's okay let's take King
f7 now I can take on e7 or d7 there's
some work f7 move I kind of like taking
here actually my first impression was to
take the bishop but when I take your
pawns hanging Bishop still hanging and
there's ninety five ideas which looks
quite nice like I removed the knight
from covering e5 hey it's a sub pass
pawn quadruple nine thanks for subbing
the first sub of the stream subbing for
Wow twenty four months in a row two
years I really have to make it to your
badge thanks so much
quadruple quadruple nine pawn pass pawn
well I I just I have a passed pawn maybe
not so relevant here okay so my digits
hanging and Bishop e5 there's Rick f7
there's this crazy Bishop h6 actually
wait Bishop e5 or got seven Queens e6
that just looks nice
I only use too much time I still have a
lot of time that I don't want to get too
comfortable so there's there's a
slightly deeper line I'm looking at
which yeah which goes rook f7 Queen c6.r
uh cafe tonight h4 and the bishop is
basically trapped I mean there's Bishop
here I guess the line could keep going
g4 rook takes off two takes
but the nice thing about the Queen here
at Defense III and then it's threatening
all these meeting ideas if I get into h6
or and get into to g6 and then g7 or h6
the bishop is so powerful here so let's
take and now ya night h4 his idea and I
think I'm completely okay like allowing
or takes off too as long as the Queen
can't infiltrate there is queen d8 but
it's probably just too slow so not h4
let's do it so Bishop here and then g4
is the plan you'll also be safe in
playoff three or night of five or knife
at five I forgot this is a been final
tournament I have to use Ben Feingold
terminology I mean yeah knife at five is
very playable but I mean g4 is a lot
more direct I don't see any way for a
black to actually target my queen and in
this line g4 takes takes I am
threatening made into also work off one
ideas
so yeah let's play this g5 doesn't help
if g5 takes takes and Queen g6 is mate
yeah these situations don't want to oh
yeah oh that's a move it's gonna say I
don't want to be too comfortable always
have to think for think about the pony's
resources so probably now 9f5 the bishop
kind of saved it saves itself but then
it's just a nice position anything else
oh there's bishop there's bishop here
too which actually yeah which just
leaves this bishop trapped then g5 who
the line keeps going oh let's play this
I I like this move feather
I was thinking g5 takes takes and then
Queen g6 not mate this time but after
King h8 Bishop e5 just wins the game
yeah there's no increment so to be
really careful about time yeah I'm
looking for other moves for black
there's rook got six but then I can take
and I'll be up so many pawns
what's the pawn count I'll be up for
pawns in that position I guess I won I
won the two pawns and then I won c-6
well so I'm already up three pawns yeah
black bog is really trying to just make
things complicated
there's retakes oh there's that move too
but with this move okay so I can take
and then Queen g6 wants to take on f2
but let's let's go for this
and the mess so I force the Queen trade
that I win the rook and it's just an gg
okay so now I'll reopen the chats ooh
I destroy the chat no the child is still
here although chats yeah that was a nice
start back in Dawson let me move up this
alert box so I'm not blocking it
thanks Bracken Dawson subbing for 15
months Bracken Dawson had a comment
earlier saying I was dropping pieces
while dragging a lot recently thought my
mouse button was failing my finger was
weak or my finger was right weak turns
out my USB 3 ports emits some 2.4
gigahertz noise from the unused
terminals that sounds complicated and
also slightly annoying what's messing
with the receiver moved to a pure USB 2
ports good job for troubleshooting yeah
hello to so many people lewbert lost her
thanks for selling me it's been so long
since I've I've had lobster at least
food lobster food but yeah thanks for
subbing for 7 months so I think overall
that was a smooth game I actually
haven't encountered someone who tries to
transpose until I got mainline Slav from
a London another sub the answer is 42
thanks for subbing like I've seen that
name before or maybe I've just heard
that that phrase before
mini name says I'm 800 ello on chest
comm and I was wondering how I can
improve my game yeah at that at that
rating tactics and blunders determined
most of your games so solving a lot of
kind of basic tactics will get you a far
away and then just playing a lot and
then being proactive and then going back
and looking over your games looking over
your your common mistakes and then try
and find some tendencies and try and
figure out kind of what sort of mistakes
can be minimized but I guess that advice
can apply at all levels not just a 800
level so in general I'd like to do some
like just some post analysis but I think
that was a pretty smooth game IG bob
says congrats on your win over Feingold
the other day even though the match was
like watching mommy mommy and daddy
fight yeah wonder how many people felt
that and Highmark 89 thanks for subbing
so yesterday I did a somewhat long Q&A
stream I answered like a lot of general
improvement questions yeah it's it's
interesting how many questions there are
about like I'm so in so rating and what
should I do to improve should really
like have some maybe you have some
specific YouTube videos for different
rating ranges or just like a general
resource video but yeah my general
answer is it's different for every
player analyzing your games is very
important
playing stronger players solving
exercises having a balanced of study of
study methods working with a training
partner working with a coach a lot of
things to do to to
prove yeah I played I played Simon and
none in the same the same week it's been
a good week I'm not yet a GM
unfortunately despite my results but
maybe someday
firedog eleven thanks for subbing yes I
was really happy to find 92 I feel like
this is this is a very like just obvious
move when you when you you have
experience in this sort of structure it
took me longer than I would have liked
to actually find I mean we could you can
see what the computer says
probably will just insult me my t2 is
not up there look so 95 ah 95 is another
idea idea f3 get Prophet says you're a
GM in our hearts does that mean your
hearts are are not perceiving reality
correctly that's okay I'll accept that
makes me feel slightly slightly stronger
whoa it's firedog gifting their first
sub to the channel
firedog gifting some black jumbo thanks
so much firedog 11 and john welcome back
and parlament maker also welcome back so
this is a the May I think it's called
the may chest mayhem there's a guy
thinks I be the Eagle triggering the
link in the chat it's being organized by
Ben and Karen I assume Ben's playing but
maybe he's commentating I don't know or
maybe he's so low rated that he's not
appearing on the standings